moorea pool was calm a day after the
deadly fighting ukrainian army units
have withdrawn from the center of the
port city on friday a gun battle broke
out when pro-russian separatists stormed
a police station in the city local
officials say seven people were killed
and almost 50 wounded the government in
Kiev claims 20 separatists and one
Ukrainian soldier died meanwhile in
Donetsk and Luhansk local activists
continue preparations for Sunday's
disputed independence vote separatists
are calling on more than 3 million
people to vote on whether the region
should break away from Ukraine they're
following the example set by Crimea
which was annexed by Russia in march on
Friday Russian President Vladimir Putin
attended Victory Day celebrations in
sebastopol the Crimean port where
Russia's Black Sea Fleet is BAE
it was his first visit to the peninsula
since annexation ovarian I am certain
but 2040 will go into history in the
history of our whole country as the year
when all the citizens here the people
she resolutely decided to be together
with Russia India pollutants trip to
Crimea met with criticism in Washington
and other western capitals our view is
that this trip is provocative and
unnecessary Crimea belongs to Ukraine
and we don't recognize of course the
illegal and illegitimate steps by Russia
in that regard Western leaders want
Putin to use his influence to help
deescalate the tense situation in
eastern Ukraine